and thank you for joining us at 11 on
this wednesday night i'm brian loftis
and still developing at this hour metro
homicide detectives
on the scene of a deadly shooting
happened in the far northwest valley
tonight
now this is all unfolding near durango
and elkhorn
sasha loftis joins us live from that
part of town with what we know so far
just gathering information at this point
here's sasha
yes brian still gathering information on
this situation we are off of elkhorn
near durango right now the whole road is
blocked off
north of durango we're told this
happened in a neighborhood around this
area again a confirmed shooting and
homicide situation
in the northwest valley so avoid this
area if you can again road closure
elkhorn north of durango shutdown so we
are waiting on a briefing from police
again limited details at the moment
but we can tell you this is a homicide
investigation a confirmed shooting
and there are some road closures in the
area a major police presence now a
briefing is set to take place a news
briefing
in just a little while at 12 15 in the
morning we will of course bring you
updates as we get them we'll bring that
to you live
online and of course have the latest for
you coming up
for 8 news now good day at 4 a.m but in
the meantime again a shooting
homicide here in the northwest valley
near durango and elkhorn
make sure to stay with 8 news now for
the very latest as we continue to gather
information in this developing situation
for now reporting live tonight sasha
loftis 8 news now